>>So, here I thought I was
studying videogames, and I still am,
but it turns out video games
are just a Trojan Horse
for studying interest-driven learning.
So, in fact, is it about the games?
I don't think so.
I don't think it's about the games at
all except that games are very good,
they're very well-designed,
both for learning,
but also to capture interest,
to be captivating, motivating.
And in schools, for example, we
have the luxury of ignoring interest
because we simply say, "Well
you must," rather than,
"Here's why it's inherently
compelling."
So, is it about games?
I don't think so.
It's really funny to me that
I'm still a game scholar.
I run a games conference, I do
everything around video games,
but really games are just an easy
context to look at what it means
when kids actually are engaged
and care about the subject matter.
>>I study thinking and learning
in the form of online games.
So, it's an interesting
intersection between video games,
and online cultures, and
social networks like Facebook.
It kind of has ramifications
for both,
but I do large empirical
studies of what kids are doing
and what's the nature of the
intellectual side of online play
of all forms, how do games
matter, what matters about them,
and how do we save the world.
>>So, we ran a two-year
afterschool program.
And before we even had to recruit
kids, we had a waiting list
of parents who had heard about it,
heard we were interested in doing it,
and were sending us their kids.
It turned into being all teenage boys
and now that's become a
real interest focus of mine.
My PhD is literacy studies,
and yet until I had two boys
of my own I had never
even paid attention
to the literacy crisis with boys.
And it's been around
for the last 30 years,
but no one's really
ever called it out.
And the more you investigate
it, the more troubling it is.
>>Teenage guys in America
are really suffering.
And they're definitely falling out of
school and disaffiliating with school
at a rate that's really alarming.
So, I've become really
interested in that,
mostly because if you study
video games a large swath
of your population is teenage guys.
So, for me, when I started doing
studies around science, and literacy,
and civic engagement, around online
games, when the biggest population
of those games is teenage guys and
they're not faring well in school,
it begs a real question, what's
happening in this space between kids
and their school world, and
their school identities instead
of their game identities and their
work they're doing around games.
>>So, when we first started
I had this great idea.
I wanted to create what I was
calling a bridging third place
between school and games.
I thought maybe we can create a
world in which kids will play games,
they'll do intellectual practices
around games, but I can play kind
of a translator and help them
understand how that relates to school
and sort of trying to buoy up
that connection between reading
around games and reading in school.
So, I had this fabulous idea.
It was so naïve and so hilarious.
First semester we were going to build
a guild website and we were going
to learn digital media
design, we were going to write,
we were going to read, we were
going to do all this complicated,
multimodal website stuff.
Had this great idea, kids came
in, it took a whole one month
until I realized this was the dumbest
approach in the entire universe.
>>The first big meeting we
had I start rolling out, like,
"We're going to build
a game website."
And I talking about all the
structured curricular kind of stuff.
And these were not
heavy-handed, lame activities,
I thought these would be really cool.
And literally the guys, I
called it the "let me know
when she stops talking" problem,
because literally they went
from totally engaged,
leaning forward,
to the moment I started
talking they leaned back
and they pulled their hoodies up over
their head and they sat like this,
like, let me know when
she stops talking.
And then when I stopped talking and
we got to game, hoodies came back
and they totally plugged
back into playing WoW, right.
And I thought this
isn't going to work.
If they don't care about any of
the stuff I'm yakking at them with,
this entire lab is
going to fall apart.
>>So, I took all of our plans, I
threw them out the window and I said,
okay, structured stuff --
not going to work.
If it smells like school,
they're not going to touch it.
If I talk at them, they are
not going to listen to me.
So, we're just going to do
this weird, radical thing.
We're going to sit back, we're
just going to resource them,
meaning that we're going
to play next to them.
When an interest comes up we'll
be like, "Hey, well, you know,
the place to read more
about that would be X."
So, when kids got interested
in the WoW graphic novels,
lo and behold, we ran out to Borders,
bought a whole bunch of them,
brought them back and we're
like, oh, look at that.
It turns out we have
WoW graphic novels here.
You could read that, right.
And once we turned it
around to resourcing,
and much more of a follow-
their-interest kind of model,
everything shifted and it worked.
>>For example, we had a reader
that was in tenth grade who read
at the sixth-grade level, was
not faring well in school.
I handed him a fifteenth-
grade-level text from the game
and he's reading it with
absolutely fine comprehension,
94- 96 percent accuracy.
So, we had this massive disparity,
why suddenly are they reading,
if you let them choose the
text, why are they reading
at this incredibly -- much higher
level of comprehension and performance.
What it came down to was something
called self-correction rates.
When they choose the text,
when they care about it,
they actually fix their own
comprehension problems more
than two times as often as when
they don't care about the text.
It's kind of stating the obvious, but
we forget it in schools all the time
that if you care about
understanding the topic, you will sit
and work through, you will persist
in the face of challenge in a way
that you won't do if you
don't care about the topic.
>>What I'm trying to say is rather
than treating kids' interests
as a means toward your
educational goals,
trying to treat your
educational materials
as a means towards their goals.
So, the model of pedagogy
behind it is really radical.
It's to say that teaching
would look a lot more
like community organizing, where
the first question is "What do you
as a community want to accomplish?"
And then your job is to figure
out how do I marshal resources
to help you accomplish that
and along the way to tool you
up with practices,
knowledge, dispositions,
that you keep for a lifetime.